beleza pessoal tudo bom
eu não podia começar o meu papo com você
de uma forma diferente porque isso
porque logo a nissei minha caminhada na
unisinos meus colegas me incomodavam pra
caramba porque eu falava com as mãos
ele comandava e falavam dizendo que o
cara trabalha as pessoas com isso tira o
foco delas segundo um papel segura uma
caneta ituana
por ironia do destino dez anos depois eu
estou aqui eu continuo falando com as
mãos mas agora eu tenho um propósito
enfim que eu quero falar pra você eu fui
convidado aqui pra falar sobre a questão
da coragem de começar algo novo
antes de começar a falar eu quero fazer
uma pergunta pra vocês
será que começar algo novo dá medo
a gente fica nervoso o coração bate
rápido forte a mão treme
é difícil eu não sei quanto a vocês mas
pra mim sim
isso sempre acontece alguns já me
conhece outros no entanto eu sou o prata
da casa foi formado em administração em
curso de gestão para inovação liderança
e eu tive a oportunidade de me formar
super cedo no formato 21 anos e aí logo
depois de formado para ser mais exato
duas semanas depois eu fui e me
matriculei em gay porque na minha cabeça
era muito claro eu era novo e estava
cheio de gás
eu não queria parar de estudar e
principalmente eu não queria estudar
depois de velho e aí está a falar em
matrimônio gay e qualquer ponto que o
que eu pensei nisso
o que eu quero fazer e lembrei do meu
pai que sempre falava que estava todo
administrador tem que entender os
números das empresas
bingo confesso nunca foi o pelé das
exatas e aí eu decidi eu fui fazer mba
em finanças
foi muito legal aprendi bastante mas
acho que mais do que isso a parte
técnica ea parte financeira eu descobrir
aquilo que eu não queria e quando a
gente não sabe o que a gente quer saber
o que a gente não quer
já é meio caminho andado a minha
história no clube e no empreendedorismo
ela começou assim eu saber
ela começou do nada durante um estágio
no qual eu conheci uma menina especial
ea une falou que tinha deficiência
papo vai papo vem ela me falou da lei de
cotas da dificuldade das empresas em
contratar pessoas com deficiência
não sei por que mas aquilo me fascinou
talvez você estava fazendo uma cadeia de
negócio e eu cheguei numa encruzilhada
eu queria fazer uma piscina com ondas
mas eu vi que era inviável
e aí foi criado o projeto mão na moda
simples mas o objetivo uma roda é
capacitar as pessoas com deficiência
para ingressar no mercado de trabalho
foi muito legal fazer mas foi um projeto
acabou tocando a vida seguir em frente
me formei fui trabalhar aí um dia
trabalhando recebeu a mensagem
eu como abrir uma empresa ela tá aí eu
achei que era brincadeira mas não era e
aí quando eu vi que o negócio era sério
a gente começou a fazer um brainstorm e
foi ideia a ideia até que chegou um
momento que não dá pra acreditar
esse meu amigo me falou 'o cara no ano
passado a gente criou uma empresa com o
objetivo da inclusão das pessoas com
deficiência no mercado de trabalho
eu tinha criado uma roda e aí a gente
juntou a ideia ea gente já tinha uma
empresa só faltava de fato começar eu
confesso que eu pisei porque é louco
mesmo eu fiquei pensando pensando
pensando com o que eu vou fazer para
tocar isso pra frente eu lembrei de um
amigo meu um ex professor chamado filipe
campelo que na época da mão na roda me
incentivou a tocar o trabalho e fazer
não desiste
se precisar de ajuda me liga porque o
meu pai trabalha com atendendo às
pessoas com deficiência e médico do
trabalho
felipe gustavo vão tomar um café
beleza ea gente veio aqui na própria
ensino naquele café e eu falei de cara
dessa forma que eu tenho de falar solto
os bons ventos que me trouxeram até ali
e aí falei pra ele e ele falou para o
tabu que é legal o seguinte parece que o
tal que o gustavo borba foi um evento e
estão lançando um edital para incentivar
o empreendedorismo
chama-se primeira foi a prime não prime
primeira empresa a sério era tudo que eu
queria ouvir sair daqui correndo tinha
uma pista
liguei para o meu amigo eu falei cara
não tem noção dá pra fazer ea partir daí
a gente foi atrás do meu amigo ligou pra
esse outro amigo e os dois viraram meu
sócio do futuro
a gente foi atrás do prêmio
a gente se inscreveu no prêmio caixa
levantando nosso primeiro caneco
e aí que a gente que é uma coisa legal a
gente começou a trabalhar no universo da
inclusão das pessoas com deficiência
nesses cinco anos que eu foquei na
questão da inclusão da pessoa com
deficiência eu aprendi muitas coisas
eu aprendi que ser diferente é normal
que a nossa vida é muito curta é muito
preciosa para simplesmente deixar o
tempo passar e que a gente trabalhando
naquilo que a gente gosta a gente
descobre uma energia que a gente sabe
que acredita que a gente não tem ea
gente é capaz de transformar o nosso
sonho em realidade
dentro disso que aconteceu foi não foi
muita situação que não fazia idéia de
como a gente resolver uma simplesmente
pela vontade a gente foi melhor ainda e
assim fui aprendendo e aí eu descobri
que é possível sim transformar um sonho
em realidade
já como diria o nosso amigo raul sonho
que se sonha só é só um sonho que se
sonha só é um sonho que se sonha junto é
uma realidade
a partir daí começou a minha caminhada
do empreendedorismo eu comecei a
aprender e eu descobri que eu descobri
que mais o mais difícil não é começar a
abrir uma empresa mas fazer com que ela
cresça e aí sim que mora o perigo porque
aí um primeiro momento tem que aprender
o que vai fazendo aquele determinado
segmento depois que aprendeu tempo
passar para o outro e essa pessoa vai
passar pra outra e pra outra e assim vai
indo e aí começam os primeiros desafios
do empreendedorismo
nessa caminhada a gente acabou vendo que
empreender é algo muito importante mas
não é fácil a gente tem que acreditar a
gente tem que trabalhar a gente tem que
botar uma mata na massa sujar a mão
mesmo
e aí a gente vai ver o que é possível
quando a gente dá um passo abrir uma
porta da outro abre outro e assim a
gente vai indo
nesse ritmo a gente levantou alguns
pontos
o lado comportamental o respeito e
educação com isso a gente levantou a
bandeira da inclusão nesse período foram
mais de mil pessoas com deficiência
incluídos formalmente no mercado de
trabalho de um monte de aprendizagem
mas uma coisa que eu queria estar foi o
seguinte os jogos da igualdade
um evento para mais de 300 pessoas
com deficiência objetivo muito simples
mostrar a inclusão através do tratado do
esporte
para mim o esporte quebra muito barreira
quebra muito preconceito e foi aí que
foi muito legal
no final desse evento sério pensando um
cara feliz era o mesmo
enfim a gente foi indo foi nesse ritmo a
gente acabou sendo recebido mais alguns
prêmios entre eles a gente foi escolhida
uma entre as dez principais empresas do
brasil incubadas a estar apto a receber
capital de investimento muito legal uma
muda tudo
a gente viu que o nosso modelo não era
escalável e que para a gente crescer a
gente tinha que atingir todo o brasil
aí teve um problema a partir daí a gente
começou a pensar num sistema que no
futuro poderia escalar empregabilidade
mas isso não vou falar agora
enfim nesse trabalho e trabalho a gente
foi conquistando e no final do ano
passado descobrir de fato e realmente é
possível transformar esse sonho em
realidade
e aí eu comecei um novo sonho a gente
começou uma estátua não só focando na
questão da pessoa com deficiência porque
não só ela que precisa uma ajuda para
ingressar no mercado de trabalho hoje a
gente vive num mundo onde cada vez mais
a gente tem que fazer aquilo que a gente
gosta isso inclui também o trabalho
estava em um novo sonho estava aí uma
nova empresa
o que eu acho legal de falar hoje o meu
trabalho não é simplesmente o meu ganha
pão
é a minha forma de lutar por aquilo que
eu acredito hoje eu posso me posicionar
muito bem
eu digo que eu sou a resistência eu sou
aquele cara que não aceita mais fazer
aquilo que não gosta talvez porque isso
conector talvez isso ensina minhas
escolhas mas eu não consigo vou fazer o
que eu não gosto você é um cara médio
isso não tem espaço mais se eu conseguir
o que eu faço eu não vou nem sentir eu
simplesmente vou fazer assim que vai
indo foi indo foi indo foi indo e viu
que a gente está passando por um novo
momento eu não sei se a gente já tá os
agentes a impressão que era digital área
digital proporciona por chegar em todos
os lugares do rio grande do sul ao acre
sinto me falou aqui não existe não
acredite tem pessoas da empresa e eu
tenho certeza que tem pessoas
o lyon não gosto a internet nos
possibilita chegar em todos os lugares
entre outras coisas um dizem que era
digital era do conhecimento e até um
livro e disse que o mundo é plano que
não tem mais barreiras
enfim nesse ritmo existem várias por
oportunidades
hoje infelizmente o brasil tem uma uma
coisa é complicado
cada vez mais a gente vê que seja por
políticas seja pelos incentivos sem
empresário no brasil é muito difícil ser
empreendedor
da mesma forma agora imagina vocês as
startups que tem que nascer e gerar
resultado não tem tempo pra testar
prototipar porque o nosso sistema não é
feito por isso então um para como a
gente pode definir isso
exemplificando mais uma criança que
acabou de nascer aí olha para elas assim
levanta a mulher que corre
não é à toa que os nossos números dizem
quantas empresas do brasil nasce e se
não não vou defender esse ponto foi
quero trazer esse exemplo e aproveitar
esse espaço para fazer a minha crítica
trabalhando no segmento de carregar
eu escuto uma unanimidade por parte das
empresas
a gente contrata pela parte técnica e
demite pela parte comportamental
isso não é uma novidade é uma coisa
muito comum
e aí eu fico de cara
por isso que eu me posicionei não vou
continuar falando mas isso eu acho que
eu já deixei bem claro eu acho que não
tem mais como a gente fazia isso porque
isso é muito caro custa muita energia eu
fazer aquilo que eu não gosto me consome
para a empresa da mesma forma fazer
aquilo contratar alguém para fazer o que
não gosta de era muito tempo e aí eu
estava vindo do aeroporto e eu comprei
uma revista especializada em rh e o
brasil ganhou mais um título a gente é o
campeão de horas extras 20% da população
brasileira trabalha em média 11 horas
por dia eu não sei quanto a vocês mas
quem trabalha 11 horas
ama o que faz talvez responda diferente
não sei se no nosso cenário no brasil e
é com isso que hoje eu digo eu sou
resistência eu digo que eu faço eu
acredito eu faço o meu protesto e verde
está na rua com a cara tapada eu vim
aqui de cara limpa de peito aberto
olhando para frente essa é a forma de
lutar ea minha bandeira é o trabalho
deixe-me dentro do caminho que eu vim
percorrendo que eu venho correndo que eu
tenho 28 anos então acho
sou muito novo pra dizer que eu já
aprendi alguma coisa que eu tô
aprendendo muito
eu trago cinco pontos comigo o primeiro
tem responsabilidade pelos próprios atos
eu gosto muito do homer simpson mas tem
uma frase dele que eu discordo eles
assim a culpa em mim e eu coloco em quem
eu quiser não é deficiência culpa é tua
então a responsabilidade pelos atos faz
com que a gente cresça talvez a gente
sente uma dificuldade toda a gente tem
uma alegria mas enfim chamar isso pra
gente
encarar o medo o medo talvez seja o
nosso principal instinto é aquele de
preservação ele nos aguça ele identifica
quais são os potenciais perigos e aí que
tá potenciais perigos nem tudo é perigo
real
então a gente tem que sentir se medo
vivenciar esse medo e aí ver pois perigo
real vou botar em vida me arrisco opa
minha vida está em risco vai passar esse
perigo não é real para frente
na pior das hipóteses eu descobri que
estou vivo eu posso continuar eu tive
uma experiência fora isso a liderar por
exemplo não sei nem como falar pra você
do que a questão de lembrar por exemplo
talvez uma simples frase os meus heróis
morreram de overdose e aqui essa pra mim
é uma das principais barreiras por
empreendedor
existe a dificuldade é sério é muito
bonito falar que faz o que gosta que
tudo mais mas isso não garante que vai
ser fácil vai ser difícil pode apostar
mas se eu acreditar com o coração é
possível porque acreditando com o
coração é a única forma de transformar
sonhos em realidade
ao menos pra mim quando o combustível
externo e uma hora vai acabar
e quando isso acabar o que vai acontecer
eu olhei pro lado vi aquele vazio e
voltar à deriva e se eu acreditar com o
coração o mundo vai acabar da mesma
forma não vai ser diferente porque
acredita ou não que as coisas vão ser
mais fáceis para mim em termos da da
vida proporcionar isso
mas quando tudo ficar escuro quando tudo
ficar complicado eu vou tá ouvindo e aí
eu sei que está na hora de acordar e
abrir os olhos e levantar um abraço